Eh bien bonjour comment allez vous
Nous ça va extremement bien je suis avec mon collègue Maxenss
Oui
Tu vas parler comme ça toute la vidéo ?
Oui *Ha ha* c'est affreux
Les amis aujourd'hui il est temps, enfin ça fait un mois  qu'on ce retient de mater se qu'il se passe sur le #tournelapage
C'était dur de pas regarder de pas se spoil j'avais trop envie de voir ce que l'ai gens on fait
J'en ai regarder 2 ou 3...
Au début tu sais non mais...
On va vous spoil 5 idées du livre, il y en a 36 au total.
Et c'est les 5 seuls idées où enfait vous devez être créatifs.
Ça serait trop facile de vous juger si on ne se jugeait pas nous même.
Donc on a nous même rempli ces pages
On ne sait pas ce que l'autre a fait
et on va découvrir, ça va être amusant!
Première page sur laquelle il faut dessiner, il s'agit d'une BD c'est l'histoire d'un mec
qui rentre dans un bar, qui ouvre sa chemise.
j'adore cette vanne
Une fille est choquée mais il manque la dernière case de la BD
donc on ne sait pas ce qu'il y avait sous la chemise, il faut qu'on dessine ça
le premier "tu veux pincer mes tétons?"
*blanc*
Ouais c'est pas mal en tout cas elle a très bien refait le mec c'est incroyable, elle s'est plus concentrée sur la tête du mec que sur la blague qui fallait refaire.
deuxième dessin, *rire* là pour le coup on voit les tétons, c'est pas mal finalement la chute c'est homme qui a en fait a une paire de sein
deuxième dessin, 'il rigole' la pour le coup on voit les tétons, c'est pas mal finalement la chute c'est homme qui a en fait une paire de sein
voila cette vidéo est maintenant -18 et nous rapportera pas d'argent, on peut l’arrêter maintenant ?
AH PAS MAAL, pas mal, un très joli dessin, ça se donne les moyens
"HAHAHAHA" Il s'est pas cassé les couilles, Atchoum! C'est pas mal
Elle fait Ahh! genre c'est marrant parce que c'est la que tu vois que les cerveaux sont différents
En voyant ça, il se dit : Ah mais c'est quelqu'un qui va être dernier alors que non
Mais du coup ça doit être la fin de l'histoire, c'est juste qu'elle éternue. C'est vraiment bien Bravo !
Suivant! "Hahaha" il dessine trop bien c'est abusé
Oooh! il a fait un inception "oui je sais c'est pas très clair mais bon." Mais si, c'est clair
Oooh! Un Classique mais.. (Rire de Squeezie) tout le monde a eu cette idée, de lui mettre une paire de boobs
Il y a un sein plus gros que l'autre comme dans la vraie vie. C'est vrai, comme nous on a une couille plus grosse que l'autre, vous finirez moins bête a la fin de cette vidéo
SUIVANT
"OOH" *Il lit* Omg! Je suis aussi fan de Squeezie. Ah c'est pas mal c'est miiignooon !!
Le feutre et tout... le tracé est parfait hein
mais mec moi c'est tâche à côté, enfin en même temps je sais vraiment pas dessiner
"Je suis Thierry Hardisson"
Pas mal ptite vanne et tout bravo ya un effort
Tu vois faire les bras qui vont dans les manches comme ça c'est exactement ce que j'ai pas réussi à faire sur le mien
Ah j'ai hâte de voir alors du coup
AHHHHHH le boobs mais alors avec un boobs en plus ça marche pas mal
Y'a une fille qui s'est fait greffer un troisième sein
Non c'est du fake ça
Ah bah mec
Tu va m'amener sur un site bizarre. Mais c'est fake !
Non non, non non
*lis* c'est un canular "AHAHAH"
Non,non regarde bien *rire*
Maxenss c'est à nous de montrer ce que nous avons fait sur cette page
On commence par qui ?
On fait un pierre-feuille-ciseau. 1,2,3 PIERRE FEUILLE CISEAU !!
ok, c'est plutôt rapide
C'est toi qui commence. Ok je commence t'es prêt ?
QUOI-AH-AH ??
Mais t'as géré mec pour ton dessin
Bah ouais j'ai géré mec tu sais ce que j'ai fait ? J'ai tapé gros ventre sur google pour m'en inspirer c'est véridique
Et toi ?
Alors moi du coup c'est un monsieur à côté de sa maison et qui dit "bonjour à tous moi c'est Anthony !"
AHAHAHAHAH
T'AIMES BIEN ?
Super !
On passe à une planche où Brutus, qui est un personnage du livre s'est fait recalé d'un salon de tatouage
Et du coup c'est à nous de lui dessiner des tatouages sur les bras, le corps enfin voila comme vous voulez
C'est parti !
OHHHHH, trop beauu
Attend trop beau et la personne dit quand même "en manque d'inspiration"
Ouais genre
J'auto-spoil ce qui va se passer après
T'as réussi à faire des tribals et j'y arrive pas du tout
c'est pas tribal c'est maori attention
Ah excuse moi OULAH
Putin mais c'est fou !
Le lol sur la tête il est incroyable, il est...
Ouais on dirai qu'il est déjà sur le dessin
Parce qu'il est deja sur le dessin en fait.
Ah oui ok *rire*
Deuxième !
Oh c'est mignoon, ohh même Brutus est fan de Squeezie
Troisième, oh mec c'est drôle
Il a refait mes tatouages c'est le crabe regarde c'est
Ah oui je reconnais
ça c'est le crabe, ça c'est la chouette qui est là,
c'est une super bonne idée. C'est vrai très bonne idée
SUIVANT !
Ah c'est mignon. C'est dur parce qu'on se rends pas compte mais la page c'est ce format là donc c'est pas hyper grand non plus
Bien joué
*Lis*
Ah enfait je crois que c'est un mixte de tout les pires tatouages
Ouais tu sais la ligne... Oh OUAIS OUAIS OUAIS OUAIS
Ya le dauphin ! le fameux dauphin
Quelle horreur !
Bien joué. Et désolé à tout les gens qui ont ces tatoos hein
On est vraiment désolé pour vous
Mais après on juge pas hein, "Only God Can Judge You" de toute façon
Ohhhhh !
*lis*
Bah franchement on pourrai croire que c'est le bordel genre mais non
Nan mais en plus elle lui a ajouté des cheveux c'est hyper beau
Un tatouage cache cheveux pour les chauves c'est une super idée
Super idée...
On a dit qu'on parlait pas de ça en public
J'en fais des chansons voila j'essaye de cacher que je deviens chauve et toi t'en parle comme ça publiquement
Max c'est à nous !
Alors on a déjà vu l'idée là mais bien sur j'ai pas oublié le petit carpe diem
Et je me suis permis de le styliser au niveau de la tête
Voila on retrouve une couronne et ici à nouveau la maison d'Anthony qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
Là ton tribal j'ai essayé de le faire j'ai aucune idée de comment
Ah ça pour toi c'est un tribal ?
Ouais.C'est le tribal king parce que tout le monde bouge ses fesses que les femmes oublient leurs complexes
T'as vu je me suis appliqué sur la couronne
Mais franchement la tête est incoyable
Bon. Puisqu'on en est là c'est à moi tu es prêt ? C'est parti
*rire* C'est des logo
Elle est deguelasse. Oui !
Mais l'idée est très drole. Mais ah c'est sale
On dirait que le mec du coup s'est tatoué des contrefaçons
Nan elle est bien. Très sale mais bien
Page suivante c'est tout simplement un mec en chaussette-tong, sauf qu'il est pas content de ses chaussettes
il veut caser des motifs, c'est donc à nous de le faire
Alors là il t'as créé un logo.... C'est des chaussettes corps de lâche
Jpense il te fait une proposition là. Ok.
Il veut que tu lances une marque de chaussettes... Ok.
Ohhhh (trop mims) c'est rigolo
Alors qui adore les chaussettes hyper originales je kiff j'aimerai les avoir en vrai
Ah ça reprend mes tee-shirts c'est deux à moi et tu veux que je te dises
Jpense qu'il les a achetés, il les a mis devant lui, il a pris le livre
Nan il a pas fait cet effort là il est aller chercher sur internet
Ah oui !
Ohhh ya de l'effort elles sont stylées j'aime beaucoup
Moi je veux celles là stp melanie tu me les crées ?
waa..aooo
Eh t'as la petite girafe là ! Ouais ya la girafe
La ya eu un début de coloriage puis l'envie est partie
en cours de route...
Alors il a eu la même idée que moi et les tatouages mais pour les chaussettes
Il a fait des logos !
T'es prêt je te montre les miennes ?
C'est des chaussettes Natsu. Oh elles sont trop belles
Elles sont trop stylées mec je les veux
La vérité c'est que je voulais en faire un motif répété comme on a vu mais j'ai eu la flemme
Le dernier !
Ouais le dernier il a vraiment pris
*rires*
Tu te moques de mon shiba ? de Natsu ?
On dirait un dessin d'enfant vraiment
Alors moi écoute, le blanc ça m'allait pas j'ai essayé de tout repeindre en noir
C'est génial  *rire*   Noir doré
Et je me suis dit des claquettes on va rajouter des petites marques voilà,
Ya une claquette poivre blanc et une DDP
Bah j'ai hésité a faire exactement pareil
Eh bah tu l'as pas fait
Quatrième idée, un grand méchant menace de détruire la planète il faut lui dessiner : Son visage
Oh il est stylé mec trop bien
ya un délire Rick et Morty
Ouais ouais à mort je regarde ça d'ailleurs en ce moment
Faut que je m'y mette moi
SUIVANT ! "manger"
Ah il lui a fait vraiment un tête de méchant, on est pas mal
*rire*
C'est trop bien
lui je le vois trop dans un manga
Ah c'est Colo-Sensei
Oui je vois
Tu vois vraiment ?
Je vois le truc, pas d'ou ça viens dites moi en commentaires
Ahahah
*rires* Il est pas mal il a juste pris le stickers du livre pour l'utiliser à cette page
Le mec il a pas trop de plaisir à faire le livre, il a fait "vasy..."
pas mal c'est un méchant youtube ?
Ya même un emoji et tout nan  c'est un méchant "le putaclik" on va dire
Ce qu'il y a d’intéressant c'est surtout le commentaire
*lis*
Le mec il demande quand même
C'est génial le mec il a vraiment fait :
"Ça a l'air tellement pété" (c'est bien ou pas quand même ?)
SUIVANT
oHH  je sens la pastel ça rajoute vraiment un effet dégueu
ça fait genre ça bave la *oahoooho*
Oh Ultraman c'est un héros du Japon !
Mais oui en plus il a écrit en Japonais putin trop cool
Max il est temps de montrer nos (parle francais stp squezzie)
Vas-y
T'as fait de la merde ?
*rires*
Mais mec t'aurais au moins pu faire les bonnes dimensions
C'est juste un clic droit quoi
J'étais pas sur mon ordi c'est un vieil ordi tout ça...
Mais c'est vraiment drôle parce que j'ai vraiment failli faire pareil avec toi
Et du coup je suis content de pas l'avoir fait on aurai eu la même blague en double
écoute moi j'ai fait un truc hyper original qu'on a pas vu...
Oh nan d'accord
*rires* On a tous un pote comme ça (j'ai pas compris la blague Maxenss)
C'EST QUOI ??
C'est un mec kawaï
Ahh... Mais c'est quoi à la place de sa bouche ?
Mais c'est une bouche kawaï ! Tu connais pas ?
Ah merde j'ai vraiment foiré mon truc
Nan mais... De ouf
On dirait une boule de bowling en plus *rire de Maxenss*
Heureusement que c'est pas moi qui ai dessiné les pages du livre hein
Oui !
Cinquième idée Brutus à perdu ses vêtements le pauvre il faut le rhabiller à l'aide de ce que tu peux trouver autour de toi
Tu vas découper/coller des trucs dessus ou juste dessiner
Alors qu'est ce que les gens on faits ?
C'est Tibo Inshape ! parce qu'il est musclé (Brutus)
Ouais nan c'est son logo et tout ! Pas mal aha
Tu fait exprès de rire on dirait que tu ris faussement
C'est fou t'as une maladie quand tu ris on dirais que tu rigoles pour de faux
*Faux rire de Maxenss*, puis le vrai
Baha c'est un manque de respect de ouf
Ahah Mais nan je ris vraiment
Mais nan tu ris pas tu fais semblant mec c'est fou
SUIVANT !!
Oh c'est pas mal putin il s'est fait chier
Alors ça m'a pas fait rire mais *rire* si ca me fait rire bordel
Maximeeeuh
Maxime ?? Ohh *rires* t'as fait exxprès ?
ça t'as brisé le coeur, mais c'etait pour voir ton vrai rire
Ok !
Franchement il a géré il a fait un truc trop bien je suis hyper jaloux
il a découpé pile pour que ca laisse les mains et tout putin bien joué
Ohh mais... Mais vous avez gérés a fond
Il a pris une page du livre !
Oui ahah
Il a vraiment pris une page du livre c'est génial
Et ça c'est du sopalin, et c'est très bien trouvé
Oh ca a découpé un soutient-gorge d'un magazine
La redoute ! C'est parti sur LaRedoute, c'est pas mal
C'est a nous
Ah j'étais euh... c'est cool hein mec c'est trop bien de voir ce que les gens ont faits
Oohhh tu t'es fais chier c'est stylé
Mais ouais mec
Là j'ai découpé un morceau de BD, Là un morceau de chemise et là pareil un truc d'une BD
Le casque et tout c'est stylé bravo
merci mec ! Je suis fier de toi
Alors moi dit toi Brutus ça m'a saoulé j'ai voulu changer de personnage *rires* donc je suis parti sur Lucas enfant
*Rires*
Qui porte un petit débardeur Clavin kleenex
Avec un Sarouel en mouchoirs usagés
Je sors d'un petit rhume alors ducoup je me suis dit autant pas gaspiller mes petits mouchoirs et faire une petit sarouel
Avec un petit jeu de mots sur le Calvin Kleenex
Max, bouge pas je dois te remettre le trophée de la meilleure page de tourne la page
de 2017, jsuis obligé mec
qu'est ce qu'il va m'offrir ?
Trop honoré, pourtant j'ai pas mis hyper longtemps à le faire, ça m'as pas pris beaucoup de temps
après que c'est vrai que le plus dur c'était de trouver l'idée
En tout cas merci, vous n'avez pas démérités vous non plus
Maxenss, tiens ton trophée. Ohhhh *rires*
Roh le batard
j'ai recyclé un trophée que j'avais eu dans la vidéo de cyprien
J'ai barré le quiz youtube j'ai mis tourne la page
Ohh mercii !
Peut-être que toi même tu barreras ce que j'ai mis pour mettre autre chose tu sais le trophée qu'on se refile c'est infernal
Et voilà les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo j’espère qu'elle vous a plus si c'est le cas n’hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude
mec ça fait plaisir j'ai enfin vu ce que les gens on faits avec le livre
C'était hyper cool, hyper créatif on a vraiment kiffer on a été étonné positivement, vraiment chouette
Je suis pas en personnage hein je suis sérieux
On dira qu'il est faux !! Non mais noon
La vérité c'est que Maxenss quand il est ému et tout content il prend une voix très touchante
Et moi quand quelqu'un est touchant j'ai l'impression qu'il est faux mais c'est juste que je suis un con
ça, et j'ai horreur qu'on me croit pas quand mes sentiments sont vraiment vrais
Franchement vous avez gérés c'est trop bien et #TourneLaPage
Ahahah la pire conclusion ! "Nan vraiment je vous aimes #TourneLaPage
Mec ça faisait tellement longtemps j’attendais de voir ce qu'ils avaient faits avec le livre
je suis trop content je rejoins ce que Maxenss dit vous avez étés hyper créatif
Merci à vous d'avoir participer, les prochains qui achètent le livre n'hésitez  pas à les poster sur les réseaux sociaux #TourneLaPage
On regardera ce qu'il se fait ca nous fait trop kiffer
Mille merci, je suis content d'avoir fait cette vidéo, aller Tchao !!  Ok...
Bah.. moi j'ai mon trophée donc je suis content